let's meet our nominees please welcome
for jackass presents bad grandpa steve
Proudy Steve please come up and take a
seat
steve is credit is makeup effects Steve
finished the kitchen sink and most
recently the prosthetic work on get on
up with about James Brown this is the
first Oscar nomination for Steve and
Steve I believe that you have a special
guest that you're going to introduce
that's right mr. johnny Knoxville
why does everyone giggle whenever they
say jackass presents bad grandpa because
they love it so it's wonderful to have
you here I know that this was a project
that you've done before you've done bad
grandpa so how did jackass presents bad
grandpa take place well the idea came up
from the studio a number of years ago
and around 2011 we started seriously
considering it and we wrote for a solid
year in 2011 and took it to the studio
desam do you still want to do it and
they did luckily in yeah and that's how
it can't it's a really movies you know
it's not that exciting how movies come
together but we felt we'd give a shot at
doing a whole movie with that character
but this was very unique because you
weren't just we've got we've got a
picture of you behind here this was very
unique because this was you know there's
guerilla filmmaking and then there's bad
grandpa well we're we're basically
slightly above a student film in the way
we execute things our makeup is like
stellar but our knowledge is very
minimal well we're going to we're going
to go through some of the the process
that took place in doing this makeup and
Steve I'd like for you to kind of tell
us what what was happening here and
Johnny if you can tell us from the
person sitting in the chair what some of
this was like well I would sit there for
three hours every morning and listen to
bart Mixon Jamie Kalman will huff it's
even Proudy tell the filthiest jokes
literally by the time I got done with
makeup I had no problem I was completely
in character as a dirty old man it was
wonderful and they
Lee some of their lines in with her off
because I was sitting right in the chair
for three hours and some of the lines
they would throw out while I was writing
ended up in the film so they also
contributed to the writing of the
filming all right all right Steve what
do we got going here right here is kind
of early on in the process we've got our
putting down our first big piece which
is the neck and cheek wrap and so that
the the glue down process probably took
about an hour hour 15 and then would go
into painting and then hair work here we
are finishing up his cheeks on and he's
got he's already got the bald cap back
of the neck ears nose and here we are in
paint mode pany is where it amazed me
every single day it amazed me how they
would just make everything come alive
when they started to paint it that I
it's just unbelievable to me yeah it's
creepy-looking until the paint goes on
and we used a combination of products
here skin illustrator was our main paint
medium and then we even go with packs on
some of the like the bald cap in that as
well as a rubber mask resold school
around the eyes and and here we are just
finishing that up in amsterdam by the
way this was Amsterdam everyone everyone
was on their best behavior hey and
here's the wig going on and the wig was
great we this one was tied by Steven
Anderson who's a member of our guild
fantastic work he he used a very fine
lace that we were able to just to hide
quite well and but it was still durable
enough for all the stunt work that
Johnny had to do now this is a quite a
thin wig very thin you pretty well see
through it absolutely oh but i never saw
a lace and i never saw blue I never saw
a shine from the glue what were you
using we used a new spirit gum new to us
which was
tell us of spirits from pbi really great
stuff if you haven't tried it and it
mats out it reminded me of old school
spirit gum it has that ether smell and
it mats out really nicely and once it
was on would use a little bit of wax
over top of it right on the edge of the
lace and it would that would just knock
the sheen right out of it but it never
yellowed it never got crusty or any of
those things that you run into with it
and we couldn't have that happen because
as you said the tying was so thin and
sheer that you could see right through
it yeah we shot 60 days over 10 months
and sometimes people would recognize the
character but not once did someone while
I'm pranking them recognize the makeup I
was an old man to everyone i pranked
which is extraordinary accomplishment I
mean I'm nose to nose with people yeah
definitely now because it was going to
be so close was there anything that you
did differently I think we took an extra
effort not to overpaint not to go too
theatrical we had to it had to look real
to us inches away from it so we I think
the painting was especially a part that
we took extra care in and I was really
proud because it was the three of us
working on it together any combination
of Bart will and Jamie myself and as
Johnny said that's when it really comes
to life and and I think that was a
probably one of the parts that I was
most proud of now I think we have some
of those individuals in the audience
don't we yes we do we have Jamie Kelman
and Bart Mixon right here all right
stand up fellas Jesus
how many pieces were involved in this
there were 11 pieces on Johnny's head
and one on each of his hands as well and
it was a combination of everything we
used mostly silicon but we had latex
pieces we had foam latex we had bondo
lips and hands we had silicone the rest
of the pieces so is it was truly I mean
the only thing we didn't put in was
gelatin and you know nobody wants that
there were a couple pieces you made that
would in my shorts oh yes not talking
about those here tonight we could
probably touch on those and Johnny you
were you were very physical yes in this
in this film very physical it was there
anything with the makeup that was
restricting with what you were doing not
at all it was incredibly resilient I did
a bit in the movie where I was on a
kiddie ride and I got slung through uh
you know department store window and I
stood up my hands were bleeding a little
bit but I went on to print people for 15
minutes afterwards and it it looked just
like I when I walked into the scene so
it was really resilient so none of the
glass ended up in the the appliances
themselves there was a couple little
pieces we had to pluck out of there but
it didn't damage it at all so we were
able to go right into filming more bits
that day yeah okay okay now let's talk
about taking the makeup off mm-hmm how
long did that take about all two beers
yeah not to Barris is it at first it was
a 40 45 minutes but by the end we got it
down to you guys got a weak answer so he
got it down to 25 minutes or so but we
never told the second ad that
they're always walking how long you take
and you got to keep some secrets yeah so
the official answer is 45 minutes yes 45
okay now here we get a little bit more
complicated I've got this added a little
bit more time to this definitely added
some time those days we shot the body
makeup for two days of the shoot and it
took the three hours and tacked on
another two for the body makeup so he
was a last two standing up yeah Wang
yeah right but now took it like a pro
and and we I think after the second day
though what was I wrote it out of the
script after the second day in the worst
thing is we were filming in a nightclub
for this prank we did in a strip club in
so I'd spent about an hour at the bar
you know pranking people at the bar and
waiting for the dancers to come on but
you know I was in a bar so I thought I
would have a few drinks and I got a
little liquored up and forgot to take my
shirt off in the bed I took my pan I
remember to take my pants off but I've
said it and make up for five hours and
forgot to take my shirt off so sorry
guys that's okay technically it is in
the movie just under yeah now is there
gonna be another bad grandpa why did
paramount ask you to ask that there may
be there's no plans to do one right now
but I I think it would be we had a ball
like I you know from our whole crew has
been together since jackass and I've
worked with Steve to the guys for a long
time and we have so much fun so there's
definitely a possibility great well
there's a wonderful display of the the
appliances that were used and there's a
whole mock-up of grad bust of bad
grandpa so later on when you go
downstairs you'll see all of the
wonderful things that transformed johnny
Knoxville in this young looking man in
too handsome to this character here
so thank you so much Johnny for coming
in we certainly appreciate it thank you
guys and I just want to thank all Tyrion
and Tony Gardner and Stephen Prouty Bart
Mixon will huff and Jamie Kalman we
could not have done the movie without
them literally there would be no movie
without the special effects makeup guys
and so thank you thank you
who think Johnny fruit for being here
and you're going to ask Steve to take a
seat please welcome for the Lone Ranger
Joel Harlow
joel is credited as the personal makeup
artist for johnny depp makeup department
head and special effects joel recently
finished Mordecai into the woods with
prosthetic supervisor for Jersey Boys
and will soon be preparing black mass
this is the second Oscar nomination for
Joel he was nominated for Star Trek
where he won an Oscar and we have Gloria
pasqua kasnije Gloria's credited as the
department had hair Gloria recently
finished the film divergent and this is
the first Oscar nomination for Gloria
and Joel I believe that you have a
special guest we do yes we have Mason
cook is he back there I think he's
coming up there you are you coming up
here we are
I'm not as special as Johnny I don't get
to go back there yes you are well we're
just we are glad to have you downstairs
earlier and glad to have you up here now
well thank you so it's great let's take
a look first at young Tonto okay now
here we've got a great deal of makeup
we've got a great deal of hair and we
got the crow so Joel and Gloria tell us
about this character what was involved
in all of this yeah i mean i can i can
sort of give you a little back story as
to where this character originated and
that was in 2009 johnny and i were
shooting a film called the rum diary in
puerto rico i was pulling images for
this carnival sequence that was coming
up and one of these images i had pulled
was this kirby sadler painting entitled
I am crow and it's basically this makeup
it was sort of a white face with the
black stripes and there was a crow that
you know it could have been on his head
or maybe flying slightly behind his head
we opted to go with on the head because
it is an historically accurate you know
ritual practiced by some Native
Americans there are seven prosthetics on
his face to achieve that cracked mud
look another four on his body I was
assisted by Ken neater bomber and
applying this makeup everyday he shot
yes he's out there right anywhere are
you their yard okay he shot about 80-85
days in this makeup and then the crow
The Crow was an engineering you know
challenge all in its own he has a
vacuform head cap Gloria braided his
hair and we pinned the cap on to him and
then on top of that cap he's got nylon
threaded rod they enters or exits the
wig and enters the bottom of the crow
oh there's a chamber on top of the crow
that we can open and we tighten the crow
on with a nylon nut and that holds the
whole thing together what that allows us
to do is take the crow off and on switch
crows because there were multiple
versions without having to remove the
way and Gloria maybe you can talk a
little about the week it's a wig we had
to cornrow its hair so that we can keep
it on like Joel said because on the
train at 40 miles an hour sometimes
backwards so that all the hair was in
his face so we sewed hair to his
breastplate and put threads through his
hair and anything we could do to keep
out of his face and then the we did the
feathers and we did all the leather
wrapping and Mickey Caprio so did a lot
of my my PA did a lot of feather work a
lot of leather and feathers and beating
so we did the entire headpiece now also
you bet a lot of long hair yes we do
it's probably I you know I think down
the middle of the back it's 30 inches 32
inches so you had sequences also on the
train yes with the long hair with the
crow with all that happy side down he
was upside down hanging under the train
to with his head back on the tracks with
his hair dragging that was awesome yeah
I mean there was a lot of sewing I sewed
I like employed my second-grade
potholder skills of weaving weaving in
rowing and Bijan yes all that so there
was a lot of work trying to keep it
together now Mason we saw you at the
very beginning of the film yes and then
we saw you at the end of the film it's
no I'm going to assume that you had some
rehearsals with Johnny Depp you met
Johnny Depp before you started shooting
I did we had lots of pre shooting
rehearsals and table reads and through
all that I got to see what Johnny looked
like as a normal person and then my
reaction when I first saw him come onto
stage as the
older version of tanto I was like it was
just kind of and I was in awe my jaw
dropped because of how they could
transform Johnny into the older version
of Tonto and it was just amazing it's
it's really incredible so when he when
he came on that first that first day or
when you walked onto the set and he was
there I know that you knew that was
going to be Johnny but that must have
been kind of a shock wasn't it it was it
was definitely a shock I mean it was it
was hard to get a good look at him
because all I saw was Joel running
around like a madman trying to get it
all already before we started filming
but um nothing like the truth of a child
right I mean I've got to be truthfully
absolutely no we love it what else I
can't what else was he doing well um he
was he was aggressively trying to shove
a straw into his mouth cuz he I guess he
needed a drink of water and he he was I
don't know how aggressive it yes playing
I got a running start at it yeah yeah
yeah he can't he had to get a running
start definitely okay here's a wonderful
look now let's go to one more here and
here we're in the makeup trailer and
here we see the the whole body we see
the face we said the body we see two
arms we see everything but if you
remember in the film al tanto is very
thin very almost skeletal he's so thin
so this is one of those perfect examples
of the blend of makeup and visual
effects but the planned blend so this is
totally designed to work along with
visual effects because obviously you can
put things on but you can't make
somebody skinnier so you'll tell us
about this yeah I mean you know the
nature of prosthetic makeup
is that it is additive it's not a
subtractive art I mean you can cheat
that by bringing forth you know
cheekbones and skeletal structure but
ultimately what you're doing is you're
adding bulk and no matter how you shadow
no matter how you paint your still
adding so the plan was and since we shot
this at the top and the movie you know
at the beginning of 153 they shooting
schedule johnny was bulked up for the
young tanto version so the plan was
always to apply the makeup as if it's
camera ready and then you know
post-shooting I would sit with the folks
from Lola and we would go through with
gore and I and digitally compressed the
areas that needed compression such as
his arms his shoulders his waist but I
was very much involved in that process I
did numerous Photoshop designs i was in
in the room and yeah i mean that and
ultimately what you get is a shot you
had directly before this which was a
frame grab from the film so you can see
I mean maybe not you know you don't see
the whole body there but you know you
get a sense of sort of what they did I
mean you know they they finned him down
really but using the existing skin you
know skin texture the sculpture you know
and if I could point out that Ken neener
bomber Mike Smithson and I applied this
you know it's it's like I said 17 pieces
took about eight hours to get a minute
he's shot for about a week with a few
days of pickups and then another two
hours to remove him because it was a
full-body gluin and there was no where
to hide anything what we use it was a
lot of work to most of this I always
tell us is tell us is five yeah was our
primary would come off a little easier
than the pros-aide exactly yeah exactly
ins and you know and in removing
something like this you don't want to
rush it knowing that he's going into you
know into makeup again the next day but
you know johnny is it's interesting that
both films have four
old body appliances like this here we've
got getting the appliances sort of ready
doing a little sculpting yeah look at
him go let's sculpt it away there now is
there were there were two there were two
makeups the first old-age makeup we
tested here in LA and you know everybody
approved that everybody liked it but
Mike and I knew that there was some
things we wanted to change so the second
makeup as opposed to being sculpted or
over the course of a month and a half
and prep was sculpted in about a week
you know right before shooting so you
know and here we have sort of the looks
like the whole crew together here
working putting things on the last final
touches there's Gloria with their her
headband and setting things up there
jewel is that a smile hey what that
smile Oh Mason your what does it mean
well you know I'm sorry I want to hear
more information yeah we know we don't
know we're good we're good with Mason
are we now I love this shot because I
title this shot department head hair so
this glorious where where he's buried
right yes I sent a lot of time like that
behind you yeah cuz I'm even when he was
standing oh yeah everyone who's standing
like that no because as you see he's in
a hole and they would put the dirt back
and forth so I just had to stand there
and take care of everything as they kept
changing it we kept taking him in and
out of this hole so okay and you had a
lot of great characters here we've got
William Fichtner and as a butch
Cavendish and you see him in the and the
not made up and then you see him in the
actual character yeah bill has that when
you know when we got bill you know
because initially there was another
actress late and we got him a couple
days before we started shooting him and
or wanted to change his appearance
because he is so recognizable so I
started sculpting a nose on him and just
carried it into the scar on his lip and
at the last minute I got together with
lanny mcdonald who was on my crew when
he's right out there and suggested that
we do something that we had done way
back when we worked together at steve
johnson shop which was this sort of a
lick lip augmentation you know to
accentuate the split and Bill's lip and
and Lenny came up with his vacuform
dental prosthetic that has a little bit
of wire that forces his lip up into that
scar and then we replaced that tooth
with you know silver because that's sort
of the bane of everybody's downfall in
this film and Gloria you've got a lot of
hair again working yes it's another wig
um we did it a little bit faded I mean
originally they wanted his hair to be
very black but because he was so aged
and I mean their stretch and stipple in
there too and distress we decided to do
it a little bit grayer and dollar and
it's got gray and he's got a rattlesnake
tail in his hair because he's like
reptilian and slimy and we got it from
the rattlesnake museum in new mexico
there's actual rent a museum yeah I said
we sent our friends out to go to collect
tails but yeah now here we've got here
we've got barry pepper and looking
without makeup and then looking as a
character and then looking that quite so
good on the certain days dressed please
dressed now down when we go downstairs
in the lobby you're going to see this
wig the mustache and they go t is that
down there too okay some wonderful
wonderful display that you're going to
be to speak knocked out by now here's a
shot of some of the crew yeah so tell us
about this yeah upper right hand corner
is Brian pirkle who was one of our new
mexico locals he
made up this is all for the same
sequence this hell on wheels sequence
he's made up as the geek and then to his
left that's me in a makeup that bill
Corso did on me wearing this goat
skeleton puppet because I wanted sort of
the illusion that this thing was
marrying adding me and I was its
marionette that's downstairs as well
then Robin Beauchesne as the bearded
lady all right Ron up she's out there
where's Robin sans beard there you go
and and of course Mike Smithson mikey is
the mute ventriloquist and and he you
know what you gotta hand it to him
because he grew those chops out for like
three months remember that Mason and
he's in it like that yeah okay well
those are wonderful shots we want to
thank Mason for coming and joining us
thanks so great and we'll ask everybody
to take your seats downstairs and we're
going to take a look at the clip Thank
You Mason it was good getting a little
additional information on this we
appreciate it next we have Dallas buyers
club please welcome robin mathews
earlier Robin completed when the game
stands tall and most recently wild with
reese witherspoon this is the first
oscar nomination for robin and we have a
truthfully a drouth is credited as the
department head hairstylist a group
recently finished dark place with
charlize theron and is now working on
crossbones with john malkovich and
absolutely and soon both adresa and a
steep rowdy will be working together on
goosebumps this is the first oscar
nomination for a truther this was a
great film and great character
development all the way through I know
this film was sort of in the process for
a long period of time I believe the
actors had quite a bit of time for
preparing know the actor or the director
had quite a bit of time now i should say
for this film we don't have a surprise
guest that's your surprise matthew
mcconaughey and jared leto are both at
the spirit awards as we speak both
wanted to be here we're trying to be
here in a distant workout and jean-marc
vallée the director was totally planning
on being here and ended up ill and was
not able to come but I just wanted to
know that all three of them were very
supportive of the fabulous work on this
film
the the work on this was very subtle but
very very effective as we look at this
first first clip here we see Matthew
looking healthy and we see him looking
not healthy now this was accomplished
wonderfully both with makeup and
hairstyling number of number of things
that were done because one of the things
that I would like to point out is when
Matthew was ill his hair looked ill okay
when he was healthy his hair looked
healthy so it was really a combination
of these two artists tell us what you
had going here well Matthew and Jared
both had many levels of sickness have
been many stages to portray AIDS this
was probably one of his sickest looks
probably only more sick than that would
be to add the rash called sore Bourque
dermatitis and lesions but we started
out with just the first day to be
probably pale but Matthew and Jared as
they look at their weight since we all
know they lost between 40 and 50 pounds
to play the roles then we'd add contour
on a lot of the facial bones and anytime
you see any of the body it's full body
makeup as well it's matching exactly
what's on the face meaning contouring
every bone in the body that we could
then we'd add highlight for another
stage then start highlighting and
contouring bones that we couldn't see
things that I couldn't see on their face
any longer so I had to study skeletons I
had skeletons and sculpt pictures right
next to them to figure out where those
bones need to be that I couldn't see and
then highlighting and contouring veins
on top of that which really made them
look thin and emaciated so it was a long
process as far as Matthew's hair when he
walked into the production offices which
is where I did all the changes on him we
didn't have a harem
yup trailer was shot in one but we
didn't have started one but we didn't
have one when i went to do matthews hara
so when he walked in i kind of took a
deep breath because i had not seen him
looking that then ever before but anyway
so i told him i said okay you're halfway
there let's take you the rest of the way
are you willing to do what you need to
do for me to change your hair and make
you this character and he said do what
you need to do and he was it was great
about letting me color it cut it change
the texture do everything there in the
office and he had to wash shampoo his
hair in the bathroom sink in the wash
basin little wash basin and he was great
about it and but anyway for his
healthier looks his hair was darker and
for the when he was a lot sicker I would
do the roots lighter so that it looked
like his hair was thinner and I would
change the I would change the part
slightly too and just did a few things
with the color to make it look like he
had less hair because he was sicker and
with Jared it was basically we used I
uses scarves on his head to make him
more vulnerable and to expose him more
and then of course we use you know the
different wigs for when he was you know
trying to get to Jared in a minute
because we've got some wonderful shots
of geritol so here we see another shot
with with Matthew and this is where he's
in the hospital I believe yeah he's in
the hospital here where he's one of his
sickest levels the only only thing
stickers when he's at the end of the
film at the Supreme Court but to make
him look healthier as opposed to this I
mean they were very skeletal so I used
plumpers central plumpers upper and
lower divided into four pieces to fill
out his cheeks and then reverse
highlight and contour I mean tons of
reverse highlight and contour to really
make them you know look look fuller we
shot in 23 days extremely out of
sequence so there was no time for them
to gain or lose weight for the different
parts of the film where they needed to
be 25 pounds heavier or lighter so we
just had to do it all with
makeup Jared we only had for two weeks
so everything you see with jared is
within two weeks of shooting that he
looks that heavy and unhealthy or that
sick you know and thinner and we
couldn't do dental plumpers on him
because we didn't get him until like the
day before he started shooting so it was
just Matthew that use that one of the
things that when I first saw the I think
I saw pictures from the film before I
actually saw the film and of course my
first reaction was well you know they
shot the healthy part and then he lost a
whole bunch of weight and then they shot
the you not healthy part but you were
going back and forth every day with God
and healthy and God and healthy weren't
you yeah five times is the worst that
the schedule is completely built around
the art departments needs a hundred
percent and we kept saying can we please
try to tailor it more around you know
these actors aren't really dying of AIDS
they need makeup but that wasn't going
to happen so it was a lot of back and
forth now here we have a shot of him
looking even worse this is his worst
stage that that's when he's the sickest
at the end when his medications get
taken away and and he develops this rash
all AIDS patients what I learned from my
research is that all these patients
develop three main things and that's
they get very skeletal in the face
especially in the cheekbones and the
temples and stuff like that they develop
this rash and then lesions as well now
is this the shot that has mom's
concoction it is because we had um you
know as a 4.5 million dollar budget my
makeup budget was 250 bucks we had to
struggle for that 250 that's 23 days
break that twenty two hundred fifty
bucks down and divide it by 23 days it
doesn't mean that's all we had obviously
I gave my entire kit to the film as well
but to purchase anything additional you
know I would have breaking this film
down I thought okay I'm going to use
little prosthetic pieces you know bondo
pieces or transfers for the Rajah
trashes and the lesions and
we just didn't have the time or the
budget of the money to do that so I had
to think back to old school ways and
just you know the whole thing was paint
and powder besides the gentle plumpers
every single thing you see in the film
is paint and powder you know just went
back to old school out of the kit stuff
and this right here is a hand-painted
the rash with illustrator and then I
topped it with three layers of straight
green marble concentrate using stretch
and stipple I didn't put adage Alex I
didn't want them to look old I just
wanted it to look Raschi and as the
third layer was drying I said okay what
can I make these pustules out of and I
kept studying the pictures and realized
maybe powdered milk or grits or cornmeal
or something like that and so I started
practicing on my hand figuring it out
and I realized that one little grit was
too white one little piece of corn meal
was too yellow so if I tweezer them on
one by one one grit or corn meal at a
time it made this and Matthew saw it and
you know I had the real pictures of the
AIDS patients and he's like oh my god it
looks amazing we have to do this like
Matthew this is a huge movie for you you
just lost a tremendous amount of weight
the work you're doing is insane I can't
put grits and corn meal on your face
like I can't do it and he pushed me he's
like it looks exactly like it's supposed
to look let's do it so and
the mom comment about your mentioning my
mother we didn't have any more money
left at that point so I had to borrow
the grits and corn meal for my mom's
pantry all right now let's let's think a
minute about casting okay and we've got
the character of rayon okay here's jared
leto and here's ray on now if if Jean
Marc had been here I would have asked
him how how did you end up casting
charity what did you see in Jared with a
beard and a mustache and long hair
looking like a extremely handsome guy
and we have rayon beautiful
transformation so this is where you were
talking about using the scarf yeah yeah
yeah we kept the head very very small
yes yes it exposed his face it made him
look more vulnerable and you know that
was one of the things that he was
comfortable in doing you know when when
we were doing the hospital scenes you
know because we you know we talked about
it and you know that was that was what
we come up with what's his scarf and of
course the brown wig you know the story
behind the brown wig here we've got the
brown way tell us that story again
majority of the people have not heard
that story I'm sure okay we could not
afford wig so I was trying to pull wigs
out of my wig kit and I came up with a
couple that I was really excited about I
kept showing shall mark and he said no
no no no no no no that looks too good
for rayon so I'd take it back to the
trailer and I cut holes in it and and I
would remove hair I did everything and
showed it to him again no that looks too
good and I said okay I'm going to fix
that so by this time I was just
frustrated and I didn't tell anybody
this until after the movie was over that
I just took it out in the parking lot of
the base camp in the gravel and drove
over it
a few times got it shook it off took it
back in the trailer and when when Jared
came in i said here i want you to try
this one on and so we put it on him
college i'll mark he said oh that's
great hey hey it's a good thing John
marks not here now also down with a
display set ups and everything you're
going to see a piece of that tire okay
some of the some of the tools of the
trade okay so we've got a couple more
shots here now here we see rayon really
at one of her worst yeah she was
involved in helping to create this well
she's her character is a drug user and
so she declines much more rapidly than
Matthew and my backstory on her is that
you know she was a hustler and she was
out partying for days at a time so she
probably you know she took her female or
hormones when she could afford them but
when she couldn't because she was out
partying or she didn't have any money
then her little beard would grow in her
eyebrows that i waxed completely off in
the beginning of the film would grow
back in and so she picked her skin from
you know drug use that type of stuff
blemishes things that Matthews character
didn't get and that's what this is here
i found a little trick that I totally
just discovered is that when like I said
earlier we went back and forth about
five times switching from healthy too
sick so when I tried to remove the green
marble concentrate which as you know is
not really easy to remove it would leave
little patches underneath and the makeup
changes had to be so quickly because our
director shoots without any lighting
setup we have no gripper electric
equipment crew nothing all handheld
camera it's all ambient lighting so the
entire crew of you know 70 people is
always waiting on hair and makeup and
during the makeup changes I couldn't get
all the green marble concentrate off of
his face and it left little tiny patches
like this and I powdered them over to
knock them down I realized they look
like little individual blemishes and it
was perfect so I kept having to powder
the hot spots but that's what that is it
was an
said that you know I guess that's how
great makeups created in it okay that's
great I've got a couple of more shots
here here here we see the two of you it
looks like just before getting ready to
shoot there on the set and then this is
a picture I like because here are the
two and they're bathed in the the red
light of success okay well thank you
very much can I say one more thing I
just want to say that my amazing key
makeup artist millon de Forest is here
from New Orleans Mel stand up now please
welcome all of the Oscar nominees back
on stage
before we start our question and answer
portion I'd like to read remarks made a
couple of years ago by Steven Spielberg
at the producers guild awards when he
received the David Oh Selznick award he
said no one can succeed alone an evening
like this reminds me that for every film
and TV show nominated tonight someone
reached out to give you their hand
whether all of us are working together
or competing inside this very small
creative community we're always holding
somebody's hand and I'm grateful to feel
all of your hands holding mine right now
I think it's a wonderful statement of
how all of this takes place with the the
film process the makeup and hair styling
process because it is a team and group
of people that make it happen now as we
start our question and answer period I'm
going to just point out that there are
people in the audience or in the aisles
they have microphones so if you have a
question please raise your hand will
bring a microphone to you so that so
that everybody can hear the question
that you're going to ask also if you
want to ask more than one question
please wait ask the one question and
please wait a little bit for other
people to ask some other questions okay
so we've got a great group here fabulous
fabulous work what about questions from
you the audience so hello my name is
Jeff I'd like to congratulate all of you
really amazing I work in new formats for
K and 8k and as these cameras and new
digital image acquisition formats come
along maybe this is a question more for
the larger budget films but could you
give us maybe your impression of how
that might affect your craft
Joel you want to take it and see ya well
I mean at any time you know I think this
is probably true of all of us anytime
certainly when I do a makeup I try to
make it believable for the eye so I feel
if I can do that then you know whatever
you know lighting situation we throw it
under whatever you know format we shoot
in I'm going to be okay but why do you
have to make it so detailed yeah give it
a man hear hear throw some Vaseline on
that lens Steve I totally agree with
joel and and also i think we have to
work a lot harder and closer with with
production to make sure that we see
dailies as they're going to be shown so
that we understand how what we're doing
translates and you mean opposed to the
DVD that they give you that you take
home and yeah the top ten years in your
hotel room table yeah they're all right
Gloria ya then edureetha we end up with
that same kind of situation with with
wigs lace lace lace I mean it's it's
great when you're lighting people work
with you you know but usually you see
where we shot we shot out in the middle
of you know the canyon or somewhere that
there's no real help but so all we can
do is just do our best and whack sounds
good just relax sounds great ok another
question I got a question over here my
question is for robin mathews um did you
guys not push for a higher budget for
that you know it's I mean I mean you're
really creative and I would like to
congratulate you for being nominated
with that kind of a budget so I mean
it's just sad that hair styling in and
makeup is not given so much priority and
that this should be the
a speaker's it's very important it's not
just the money for the actors but it's
really good artistic work which all of
you have been doing well thank you very
much if I had the power to push for a
higher budget I would do it every job I
have but that's not really how it works
unfortunately you know we lost our
funding for Dallas buyers club I think
everywhere maybe you know or don't know
it's been spoken about a lot in the
media I think 19 years this has been
trying to be made two weeks before we
shot yet two weeks we've lost job I lost
all the funding and matthew and
jean-marc vallée our director got
together on the phone the sunday night
before we were supposed to start start
shooting on Monday and spoke to one
another and said we have no money I'll
show up tomorrow if you show up and they
both agreed of course they didn't tell
any of the crew this so we all showed up
for work thinking everything was fine
but you know it wasn't just us that had
no budget it was the whole movie it's
just we all kind of collect it will
collectively agreed to shoot this as a
labor of love and to do it that way so
am i right that the the budget was four
and a half million it was 4.5 yeah yeah
so pretty small all the way across the
board another question hi I have a
question about thee in the one scene I
noticed Matthew McConaughey had a big
vein down the middle of his forehead I'd
like to ask how you did that um I
highlight and contour the veins as well
not just the bones everywhere but and
there there later sickness you know that
the final stages of sickness when people
are so skeletal and they lose all the
volume in their face all the fat their
veins poke out and so that was a little
trick that I came up with to really make
them look even more skeletal I mean the
actors maintain one weight throughout so
I had to figure out ways in stages to
make them look gradually sicker and
highlighting and contouring the veins is
that even when you saw on the one scene
where he's injecting his medicine the
veins were highlighting contoured but
you didn't really see him pop out until
he you know kind of held his breath so
yeah I have a question over here hi my
name is Megan congratulations to all of
you I hope someday in the future to be
sitting where you're sitting so I just
moved to Los Angeles so this is the
first thing like this that I've ever
done um my question though specifically
is and now of course I'm losing my train
of thought of to dallas buyers club
makeup artist Robin yes robin mathews
again so i'm wondering you said when you
said that you shaved the eyebrows off
were you talking specifically in the
sense that the characters shave them off
or did you actually shave off jared
leto's eyebrows and it's not what did
you cover them with because the whole
time I was watching the movie I was
staring at them and I'm just like how on
earth because with Photoshop is one
thing but on film especially with HD
it's another that that was jerez bravery
array Owens bravery since we didn't
actually meet Jared ever but she came in
and I said so how do you feel about
waxing off all your eyebrows and she
said well I just waxed my entire body so
let's go for it and within five minutes
of meeting rayon i waxed her eyebrows
off completely and we did it one more
time during the film it was a little
scared to do it three times because I
was worried they wouldn't grow back
properly now wasn't am i right that
rayon was always in character I think
when we were at the nominees luncheon
jared leto was there and robin said you
know this is the first time that I met
Jarrod because he had always through the
film been rayon and i think i'm right
and would love to have had she and Mark
tell the story but during the entire
interview that the director did with
Jared he was totally in the rayon
character never came out of it yeah he
actually apply lipstick they were
skyping to one another
and so he applied lipstick and then he's
proceeded to flirt with jean-marc and
try to pick him up and John Mark said
you know I kept waiting for Jared to go
back to Jared and say you know how I how
you doing this is the character I'm
thinking of and he never did he just
still tried picking up picking up on him
and so he got the job another player
hello saw the question with the full
body makeup that the actors are wearing
is there any preparation that's going on
when they were in a long period of time
and does it keep them cool how does it
work Steve you want to take a fish okay
they do perspire fortunately when we
shot Johnny scenes with full body makeup
it was a colder time of the year so
that's you know it sweats the enemy when
it comes to prosthetic makeup so but we
we took extra steps like with his head
makeup in that where we would apply a
topical anti perspirant called sweat
stop and that helps stave off some of
the sweat that happens we also left
channels through the makeup so he could
sweat out and not cause the makeup to
become loose but yeah you know it some
people sweat more than others he of
fortunately he did fine in fact it was a
little tough to get the makeup off and
the first day we did it he were coming
back to the hotel to remove the makeup
because we did all the makeups out of
hotel rooms we didn't have trailers or
hitting and he starts peeling the body
pieces off and he's a lot of it's still
sticking to him and I just said don't do
that that's not a good idea and he was
like that's fine as in at least it's
can't wait to get out of it and I said
you're going to have big red welts all
over you tomorrow and yeah I'm good next
day comes in big red welts he's like
you're right I won't do that again
see Mason the actors don't always know
best okay so I always listen to your
makeup artist and hairstylist Joel what
about you what was your situation here
yeah i mean it's it's basically it
becomes you know a case of trying to
maintain coolness on the set i mean this
is one of the few the old Tonto stuff is
one of the few scenes we actually shot
on a stage everything else was shot you
know on a mountain on a train in a river
but we had a cool tent for Johnny so
between shots we could get him you know
get him into a place where we could
lower his body temperature um but yeah I
mean it's you know you spend eight hours
in the morning applying a makeup and you
know for most people that's their entire
day your day at the end of that is just
starting so you know half half your job
is applying the makeup but you know
certainly the other half is maintaining
the makeup and then there's a third half
which is removing me is that like that's
the one one hole and a half it's too
many hands after eight hours of applying
how long did this shoot well gore wisely
set it up so that he was shooting
another scene in the morning the
Comanche in a tepee talking about the
treaty that had been broken so we shot
that in the morning and then that that
allowed Jonny to not come at come in and
an obscenely horrible 2 a.m. call but
rather something around six o'clock we
do the makeup you know everybody would
break for lunch we'd finish and then go
right into this diorama sequence that
you see old Tonto in you know shoot half
today in that take him out you know and
then do the whole thing the next day and
you know progressively you get later and
later and later because you know it's
just sort of the nature of the beast any
of you that have worked on a set know
that you know you can start with the
best intentions at six a.m. on monday
morning come friday morning you're
starting at two p.m.
and working until saturday morning what
a frat errday exactly another question I
got a question over here hi poli local
706 makeup and my questions for Joel and
Gloria and I'm just wondering on the
really large seen days when you had a
lot of makeups going on how many makeup
and hair people did you use and if those
days were in other states how did you
find your makeup and hair people well I
mean it's you know it's easy to say that
Lone Ranger was a big-budget movie and
certainly was it was that but every
every department on every film I've ever
been on has its budget constraints Lone
Ranger had gone down once before and I
believe they were 20 million into it at
that point so you know we were squeezed
just like everybody else we did this
entire film with a core group of five
people and then a couple other shot
people one that I forgot to mention
steve bousquet know it was sort of my
right hand in the shop I likely to
mention him and then Sabrina Wilson who
is my assistant and liaised between the
makeup department and the lab you know I
mean we structure you know we structured
this film so that we could apply makeup
in the morning and then some of us would
go back to the lab that was traveling
with us build the makeups cast the
makeups bring them out apply them the
next day we you know and we just kept
the whole thing going like that so I
believe the question was how many people
on the big days like 15 something like
that on days of I think three I think
our biggest yeah our biggest day was 12
and we got local people yeah for hair we
every state we went to we found some
local people we had people in Utah that
were traveling three or four hours and
we put them up overnight we had maybe
two people from loot Utah that were
local it was really hard we brought a
lot of our new mexico crew with us to
Arizona and Utah land and you know when
you're dealing with a peer
a piece like this everybody is in some
kind of special make-up you know and
gore puts you know multiple cameras on
the background so you can't slag there's
no such thing as a B and C you know
because you could have a/c character you
know 70 feet high so you got to make
sure that everybody's done a hundred
percent and you know fortunately we had
a great team a great team is so
important another question have question
back here hi congratulations once again
I'm curious to know how you collaborate
with the actors director to complete the
character as well as the Wardrobe from
you know brainstorming or if the actors
already come with an idea of what they
want the end result to look like and how
you you know collaborate with your own
ideas and what the director's vision is
as well you know I think that would be a
great great question for each one of you
just to briefly give an idea about
because each film is different and a lot
of times each actor is different some
some have you know a definite idea of
what what they want and some you know
I'll sit down you do it let's start with
the with Robin um well I mean we were
really really lucky because Matthew and
Jared were very very you know advocates
of the makeup and hair and they thought
it was really really important Matthew
and I sat down the beginning of the film
I had worked with him previously so we
knew each other and we went through
every single page and the script every
scene and wrote down what's your stage
of sickness here what's your stage of
illness in this next scene and did it
together decided on it together test the
looks and you know came up with with a
breakdown that Melanie and I had
plastered on our foreheads at all times
so just make sure that you know because
we were so out of sequence shooting that
we followed it and he wasn't in the
wrong stage of illness at the wrong time
and rayon after I wax off her brows and
she got comfortable with me because she
was sizing me up right before that big
time wasn't sure if you know like
whatever
so after that worked out then she
treated me just like her makeup artist
her beauty makeup artist on a daily
basis I come in and bring her pictures
of you know I thought maybe she'd be
influenced by ladies of the sixties
actresses I bring her picture Brigitte
Bardot or something and she go oh I
quite like that yes let's do that today
and so I was I was just there you know
it's her beauty makeup artist okay I
drew that my research came from my
appointment book in the mid 80s this was
set 1985 this was something that I had
done so many times before as far as
these looks when you know I had a great
assistant cat but she had she was just
born in the 80s so so but the research
came from you know a period that I had
was so familiar with and then when I met
with Jean Marc you know he had he had
pictures that he came up that he wanted
me to to look at and you know Matthew
his idea was you know he just wanted to
look like the character that he was
betraying and and however I needed to
come come up with that you know that's
what I did but between the three of us
it was a collaboration it's always seems
to be a collaboration and talked to
costumes we had a great costume
department and production design
everybody you know and you just kind of
take all that and you come up with your
character looks for grandpa it we had
the luxury of having some previous
experience doing knoxville as an old man
so it gave us a chance to take notes
from that and say this didn't work this
worked let's really hone in on making
this as streamlined as carefree as
possible as far from a makeup
perspective so we sat down with Tony
Gardner owns all terrian and we started
fresh we took a new life cast of Johnny
and we did some photoshop designs and
submitted those back and forth with
production and got a lot of notes and
changed those around but by the time we
got it into clay it's completely
different and and we
didn't kind of disregarded the the
photoshop work and and just worked in
three dimensions and but there was you
know there's input from everyone from
Johnny from the producers the director
and everybody had something they wanted
to see in it so we tried to incorporate
everyone's ideas and take it as a
collective design process Gloria exactly
you just I started when I first started
the film we started in fittings in the
wardrobe warehouse so I had penny
throwing our costume supervisor just
throwing all the costumes and different
things so we just started with the
ladies and just started making up
hairdos that went with it that went with
my research and then it's like costumes
and makeup and the director then the
actors all bring something to it they
all have an idea we just elaborate on it
so it's a group effort for sure I do I'm
like yeah i mean i've got a
long-standing relationship working with
with Johnny and certainly he is you know
my greatest creative collaborator and
collaborator no there's no makeup that
we do that he doesn't you know weigh in
on a hundred percent you know usually he
comes to the trailer with you know
images and I have ideas and you know
ninety-five percent of the time they
sink right up and we just go into you
know into building and testing you know
like i said you know when we were up
here before you know this image the
image of young tanto came about in
puerto rico after we had seen that Kirby
Sadler painting so I mean that it was
just a case of fleshing that out you
know changing sort of the test into the
correct mud and doing all that but you
know and then working with gore I mean
gore I'd worked with since pirates one
and he he paid me the greatest
compliment when we were doing the hell
on wheels stuff
because none of those characters were
scripted we came up with all those just
because we love makeup you know it was a
chance for us because I have such an
amazing team working with me it was a
chance for us to say you know what let's
put pushing the envelope here because
Gore wanted everything very period
correct that was the one place we could
kind of let our hair down and go a
little nuts and you know and without
these guys working around the clock and
weekends and you know really pushing the
envelope none of those like elaborate
you know goatman lummox geek none of
that stuff would have been in the film
it's just because we love it but gore
you know I said I told gora it's like
look we've got some specialty characters
coming for this hell on wheels sequences
like you want to know what they are he's
like now just do what you do and tell me
when I got a ringer and I'll throw a
camera on it so I mean it's like it you
know that coming from him it's like
great that's quite a vote of confidence
you know they just kept making more at
that we've got time for one more
question I have a question over here
first I want to commit to all of you for
your creative ten magical talents very
impressive Joel I'll ask you this
question what are the after effects to
the skin on these people after you've
done all this makeup all over their body
and their faces my goodness well I mean
you know like i said you know removing
the makeup is just as important as
applying the makeup you know there's a
tendency certainly as an artist for me
to once i'm finished creating to step
back and say okay that's it I've done it
but you know that's you know that for
lack of a better expression is your
canvas for the very next day so unless
you treat that canvas with the utmost
care in removal it's not going to give
you the same quality as it did the day
before so and certainly you don't want
to lose the faith of your of your actors
so it's you know it's just as important
to moisturize to you know anybody
wearing a makeup you know or anybody
doing makeup on somebody multiple days
and ro tell them not to get a facial
that is a horrible idea okay so I'm just
putting that out because I've had that
happen
not on this show but on a show way back
and i'll tell you why you glue something
onto somebody has just had a facial
that's not coming off they might as well
live with that new face that's a tangent
but yeah you got to got to be camus stir
eyes you cleaned thoroughly and you're
just very slow very meticulous and
removing the prosthetics because you
know you you you wouldn't want that you
know you wouldn't want to embrace their
skin just like he would not want to
embrace your own skin so okay you're
going to see all of these nominees
tomorrow night at the Oscars be on ABC
be sure and watch